the 9008th meeting of the security
council is called to order
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is letter dated 28 february 2014 from
the permanent representative of ukraine
to the united nations addressed to the
president of the security council
s slash 2014-136
the agenda is adopted
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i invite the representative of ukraine
to participate in the meeting
it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
i invite the following briefers to
participate in this meeting ms joyce
mitsuya assistant secretary general for
humanitarian affairs and deputy
emergency relief coordinator and mr
david beasley executive director of the
united nations world food programme
it is so decided
the security council will now begin its
consideration of item two of the agenda
i now give the floor to miss joyce
misuya
madam president
just over a month ago the war in ukraine
started
and it shows no signs of abating
children women and men are being killed
injured
displaced and traumatized
hospitals homes and schools are being
destroyed
according to the office of the u.n high
commissioner for human rights
as of 27th of march
1119 people have died
including 1999
innocent children
we know these numbers are conservative
and the tolls are far greater
cities like maripo karkiv shanihiv and
many others
bustling and full of life just one month
ago are encycled bombarded and blockaded
people in these towns lack food water
medicine electricity and heating they
are trapped
desperate
afraid
in some neighborhoods it's not even safe
to bury the dead
more than 10 million people including
more than half of ukraine's children
have fled their homes
this includes an estimate an estimated
6.5 million people who are internally
displaced in the country
according to the international
organization for migration
the u.n refugee agency reports that more
than 3.9 million refugees have crossed
the borders to neighboring countries in
the past month
madam president
our work is to save lives
the humanitarian system has scaled up to
deliver despite the spreading conflict
since february 24th
humanitarian organizations have reached
around 890
000 people
across ukraine mostly in the east with
multi-sectoral assistance
people have received food
shelter blankets medicine
bottled water and hygiene supplies
we are working around the clock to reach
more and more people in need
the un and our humanitarian partners are
working impartially and relentlessly to
uphold humanitarian principles negotiate
safe passage in and out of in-cycled
areas for one cause alone
to provide life-saving assistance
humanitarian logistics and supply chains
are scaling up every day
but treacherous security risks and
access challenges are hampering our
efforts
many routes are disrupted and
humanitarian convoys and workers are
frequently unable to pass
due to shelling
fighting and landmines
humanitarians of all stripes are putting
their lives at risk to help those in
need
there are now more than
1230 united nations personnel in the
country
working via humanitarian hubs across the
country
and there are more than a hundred
humanitarian organizations
implementing or planning activities in
every oblast in ukraine in all sectors
the brave work
of the ukrainian red cross and other
civil society organizations who are
working shoulder to shoulder with
volunteers and communities is astounding
ukraine is a humanitarian paradox
side by side with extreme violence we
see extreme kindness
profound solidarity and the gentlest of
care
i am humbled and inspired by the
tireless commitment of these people and
we must continue to support their work
where security allows humanitarian
convoys are unloading much needed
supplies
and delivering equipment to repair
damaged infrastructure
on 18th of march
after delays due to ongoing hostilities
the first u.n organized convoy reached
sumi in the northeast
the convoy delivered 130 tonnes of
much-needed medical supplies
water ready-to-eat meals and canned food
for 35 000 people as well as essential
equipment for the repair of water
systems
that will help improve access to water
for some 50 000 people
yesterday
again after delays due to ongoing
fighting the second u.n organized convoy
reached kharkiv where supplies of food
other essential relief items and
emergency health kits and medicines were
unloaded for distribution by the
ukrainian red cross society
countrywide more than 180 metric tons of
medical supplies have been delivered and
more than
470 metric tons are on the way
where we can we buy supplies from the
local market and work alongside local
efforts
but we need to move to scale
more convoys are planned for the days
and weeks ahead to reach many more
people with desperately needed aid
i'm sure david will tell us more about
the world food program and its work over
the past month and expansion of its
operations in ukraine
madam president
civilians in ukraine desperately
need this assistance and protection
but to do that all parties must uphold
their obligations under international
humanitarian law
to ensure safe and unhindered
humanitarian access to help civilians in
their homes and those on the road in
ukraine
and to allow those civilians who want to
leave to get out
we need detailed realistic agreements on
humanitarian ceasefires and poses to
allow aid in in people out
for predators
and human traffickers the war in ukraine
is not a tragedy it is an opportunity
humanitarian organizations are worried
about the risk of trafficking
as well as sexual violence exploitation
and abuse in ukraine and the region
children fleeing the war are it's
especially heightened risk of human
trafficking and exploitation
predators are luring single parents
on the road with promises of transport
and
accommodation we are scaling up our
protection services at the borders but
also in the country to make sure people
have information available on safe
options and routes
access to lines and safe shelters
humanitarian partners are coordinating
closely to not only monitor
risks of sexual violence trafficking and
abuse but provide swift and specialized
services to survivors
madam president
humanitarian partners
agree
our worst case scenario has been reached
and in some areas surpassed
this is why last week the principles of
the inter-agency standing committee
agreed to revise the flash appeal
that has rallied nearly
506 million of the 1.1 billion needed to
support the response
the refugee response plan
coordinated by the un's refugee agency
unhcr
will also be revised
the generosity and welcome of ukraine's
neighbors is remains
a bright sport in a darkening landscape
madam president
the global impacts of this war are
becoming clearer as each day of this
conflict continues
it threatens to make things even worse
in the world's biggest humanitarian
crisis such as afghanistan yemen and in
the horn of africa
these countries are already grappling
with food insecurity and economic
fragility
rises in food fuel and fertilizer prices
will heat hard now and for the coming
seasons
we are only beginning to see the breadth
of this crisis on other regions and
countries
we will all be affected
madam president
the secretary general has asked under
secretary general martin griffith to
urgently engage with the parties on
possible arrangements for a humanitarian
ceasefire in ukraine
martin has already been in touch with
both parties who have welcomed the
initiative and he will travel to the
region within days
we must find measures from local poses
to wider cease fires to save lives
protect the homes of civilians from
being attacked
their schools
their hospitals
civilians are running out of food of
energy and of hope
our aim is simple
silence the guns and save lives thank
you very much
i thank miss monsieur for her briefing
and i now give the floor to mr david
beasley
madam president thank you very much and
it's good to hear from joyce and i'll
try not to repeat much of what joyce
said but uh
it's just hard to believe that
before the ukraine crisis that things
could get any worse around the world we
were already because of fuel prices
food pricing shipping costs beginning to
cut
rations for
millions of children and families around
the world in countries like let's say
yemen where we had just cut 8 million
people down to 50 rashes and now we're
looking to go to zero rations niger mali
chad and i could go on and on and on so
now we're talking about a catastrophe on
top of a catastrophe because ukraine
from the breadbasket of the world now to
breadlines we never would have dreamed
anything like this would be possible and
it's not just decimating
dynamically ukraine in the region but it
will have global context impact beyond
anything we've seen since world war ii
so let me touch upon a couple of things
inside ukraine we've reached uh right
now about a million people over the next
four weeks we will reach two and a half
million people and by the end of may we
will have reached four million people
and then by the end of june we hope to
be reaching about six million people uh
on any given day week or month so to
speak the price tag that we're looking
at just on the food security side inside
uh ukraine is about 500 million dollars
for the first three months we've
we short about 300 million so we're
going to need to step up now one of the
things we got to be careful while we are
concerned about ukraine we can't neglect
the sahel northern africa the rest of
africa the middle east otherwise you'll
have massive migration coming from all
sides of europe and so this is a crisis
on top of a crisis and so we all know
the extraordinary
loving
welcoming arms of strangers neighbors in
poland in romania in hungary slovakia
and moldova been remarkable as i've been
there now three times just in the past
few weeks watching firsthand the
experience of people but that's the
people that have made it to the outside
to three and a half to four million
people and one way you can say they're
the lucky ones because they are getting
food they're getting shelter they're
getting help they're getting some degree
of hope out of harm's way but you have
40 million people
40 million that are inside ukraine
and we've got to do everything we can to
stabilize the food supply chain system
and reach as many people as we possibly
can because you can imagine
the farmers
are on the front lines fighting
and it's planting season for corn maze
right now for the next four weeks
well who's going to be tending the crops
then you got harvest season for let's
say week coming up in june july well if
the farmers are on the front lines
you can see we're concerned not just
about what happens inside ukraine but
also what's going to be happening
outside ukraine obviously we're
appealing to everyone involved to
deconflict give us the access we need
most of the places around in ukraine we
can reach in a lot of different ways
right now but places like marple we
can't and we need the access uh that
joyce was talking about so that we can
reach the people that are in harm's way
and don't have access to food we will be
using cash-based transfers as well as
commodities uh in-kind food itself
depending upon each dynamic of every
particular area as you can imagine
ukraine is not a small country and so
we're pre-positioning moving food
working with the government to move it
by train by truck whatever it takes and
we're working with the government to
make certain that we have the truck
drivers we need to do what's necessary
to reach the people in need so let me
just kind of capitalize ukraine and now
shoot to the outside because
as you have heard
ukraine and russia produce 30 of the
global supply for wheat
20 percent of the global supply of maize
corn
80 75 to 80
of sunflower seed oil so you can begin
to see the dynamic consequences 50 of
the grain that we buy
comes from ukraine we feed 125 million
people before ukraine
ever happen
and so you can only
assume the devastation that this is
going to have on our operations alone
already we are anticipating a 71 million
dollar increase in monthly expenses
because of fuel costs food costs and
shipping costs
that's 850 million dollars which means
that's 4 million less people will be
able to reach
just from
expense costs alone then you take
countries like
yemen
the devastation and the dependence on
russian ukrainian wheat
uh egypt 85 percent dependent upon
ukraine grain uh lebanon and in 2020
85 81 depended upon uh grain from
ukraine and i can keep going around the
world as you can only imagine
and then you compound that with the lack
of fertilizer based products that come
out of belarus in russia
you know if you don't put fertilizers on
the crops your yield will be at least 50
uh diminished so we're looking at what
could be a catastrophe on top of a
catastrophe on top of a catastrophe in
the months ahead this is why when i was
talking to
the g7
ministers secretaries of agriculture how
quickly can the world
agricultural community offset the
reduction that we could expect out of
ukraine in russia in terms of supply
demand
what at one time we were very concerned
and mostly concerned about pricing
i think we're now looking at it's a
pricing problem and maybe an
availability problem if we can't have
the offsets to what we'll lose inside
ukraine and
russia so these are very
very serious issues as we're talking to
leaders around the world how to respond
quickly to do the things necessary to
minimize the impact
globally as well as in the ukraine
itself if you go back and look at arab
spring 2008 and 2011 and 12 economic
indices food pricing that were spiking
you'll begin to see there's a lot of
similarities except quite frankly
it's much worse in some categories than
it was in 2008-2011-12
because now we have the ethiopian war
afghanistan
more climate crisis that are impacting
the sahel for example so these are going
to be difficult difficult months ahead
ahead many of you
nation states have been stepping up in
ways you've not done before but let me
tell you if we don't step up and don't
respond
we'll pay a price that'll be a thousand
times more expensive than stepping in
and doing what's necessary as we sold
for example in syria where we can feed a
syrian for example 50 cents a day that
same syrian ends up in berlin or
brussels is 70
or more per day and so
if we act
in the conflict address the needs we can
avoid famine destabilization of nations
and mass migration but if we don't
the world is going to pay a mighty price
and the last thing we want to be doing
at the world food program is taking food
from hungry children to give to starving
children please let's make certain that
we can reach them all so madam president
thank you
thank you very much
i thank mr beasley for his briefing
i now give the floor to those council
members who wish to make statements
i give the floor
to the representative of france
madame president
president
and i would especially like to express
gratitude for the extraordinary
organization
the wfp and all the humanitarian
agencies who can count on our support
with a crush
this resolution proposed by france and
mexico which should make it possible to
support the secretary general's efforts
as well as humanitarian actors who are
on the ground in order to support
civilian populations and bring them
given the humanitarian drama which is
unfolding before our eyes
it is imperative that russia respect the
geneva conventions civilians including
children
persons with disabilities
and medical and humanitarian personnel
as well as civilian infrastructures
must be protected
is
it is the unjustified and unjustifiable
which
then
jeopardizing access to foodstuffs for
the most vulnerable
pursuit of the fighting which threatens
harvest to come
the european union and his partners have
adopted sanctions
so that russia
would fall in line with the united
nations charter these sanctions do not
target agricultural activity in russia
given the world food disorder the most
effective response is immediate
cessation
russian aggression
it's also important to strengthen
international cooperation in this area
and france fully supports
the initiative launched by the secretary
general
the united nations
this initiative is geared to lowering
tensions on world food markets and
ensuring everything
movement of food stocks
should also make it possible to provide
rapid access
for agricultural products for those
countries
and to ensure world development
agro food production in africa
upon the relevant private and public
sectors
to join this initiative
which should also be
included in the efforts of the united
nations secretary general in this regard
madam president it is urgent that we
actually
france commenced
the courage shown by the people of
ukraine in the united nations
france will continue to mobilize with
all of its partners to support ukraine
and the ukrainian people france will
spare
no effort so that full light is shed
criminal allegations which once
established should not go unpunished
thank you
representative of france for their
statement i now give the floor to the
representative of mexico gracias
president thank you president
i would like to thank
assistant secretary general for
humanitarian affairs and mr amir
abdullah deputy executive director of
the world food program for their
briefings and i would like to welcome
the ambassador of ukraine to this
session
every week
there is an exponential increase
in the humanitarian drama
and the figures that we just heard
reflect
the deterioration of the situation
i just mentioned them
because we must not lose sight of the
proportion and dimension of this affair
12 million people
are impacted
3.8 million refugees and 6.5 million
internally displaced persons in just
five weeks
particularly alarming is the fact that
90
of the refugees are women and children
priority is
the cessation of hostilities
and protection of the civilian
population of ukraine
evidence of that is the overwhelming
majority with which
resolution es stroke 11 stroke 2 of the
special session
of the general assembly
of the 24th of march
has also had
significant consequences in terms of
food supplies and food security at a
world
level as we just heard
the effects are very serious both in the
immediate term and in the medium and
long runs
negotiations
and indicated that it was a priority the
secretary general has also been quite
explicit in this regard
acknowledge and recognize the intention
of the world program to support basic
needs for some three million people who
are impacted by this conflict
and
humanitarian assistance to where it is
most needed
there are limits on fuel transportation
drivers and now with the closing of the
major ports
and in security with commercial vessels
it is more difficult
in some cities such as the case of merit
the situation has become acute
and this is why we insist
on our call for a guarantee of secure
access without impediment to
humanitarianism the conflict has already
had a direct negative impact on global
food markets and energy markets
raising the prices of these products
this increase of prices
is starting to be felt in national
[Music]
therefore there will also be an increase
in the cost of operation for the world
food program
which we've just heard
and that will then in turn limit its
capacity of response
to meet the growing needs
and the new food and security which will
the efforts of humanitarian agencies of
the united nations and who have provided
support to millions of people both in
ukraine
ukrainians and we would like to commend
their generosity
madam president
resolution
to have safe and unrestricted access
and are able to do their jobs
also
we have followed with concerns
the increase in the flow of weapons
towards ukraine the proliferation of
weapons could end up
leading to greater violence amongst the
civilian population
and if these weapons fall in the wrong
hands it could also give way to other
violations of international law and
human rights
it's necessary to evaluate
to what extent
these weapons may ultimately
end up exacerbating the humanitarian
situation
clearly we deplore the use of
explosive weapons and cluster munitions
in urban zones
and should be put to this kind of weapon
mexico's priorities vis-a-vis this
conflict have been and
it is urgent to have an immediate
cessation of hostilities
and if that is achieved it's necessary
in the meantime to have pauses
sustainable humanitarian pauses to
guarantee protection of civilians and
access to humanitarian aid
of the aforementioned resolution that
was adopted a few days ago by the
general assembly thank you very much
madam president
i thank the representative of mexico for
their statement
i give the floor to her excellency ms
wendy sherman deputy secretary of state
of the united states of america
thank you madam president uh for
welcoming me to represent the united
states at the security council today
and thank you assistant secretary misua
and executive director briesley and
welcome deputy executive
of the wfp abdullah for your briefings
today
and of course i welcome the ambassador
from ukraine
it has been five weeks
five weeks
though it feels like a lifetime
since russian president vladimir putin
launched his premeditated unprovoked
unjustified and brutal invasion of
ukraine
in just five weeks
nearly a quarter of ukraine's population
has been displaced
including more than half
of the nation's children
in just five weeks
nearly four million ukrainians have fled
their country as refugees
now the world food program warns that 45
of the people in ukraine nearly half of
the people
of ukraine living in one of the world's
greatest bread baskets
are concerned
about having enough to eat
russia's ceaseless bombardment of
ukraine cities
and critical infrastructure has created
one of the fastest growing humanitarian
crises
in recent decades
russian forces have laid siege to cities
like mariopol
where citizens have been left without
food
water heat or electricity in the depths
of winter
people have resorted to melting snow
for drinking water
one mother told reporters
she could feed her three daughters
only a spoonful of honey a day
as they hid from russian bombs
now city officials say people are
beginning to die
to die
of starvation
think about that
five weeks ago
mario paul was at peace
it was in fact a bustling port city
a grain exporter that helped feed the
world today its residents are dying
because of president putin's war of
choice
the impacts
of putin's war are being felt far beyond
ukraine's borders as well
with some of the most immediate and
dangerous implications for global food
security
as has been said ukraine and russia are
both major agricultural producers
30 percent of the world's wheat exports
typically come from the black sea region
as does twenty percent of the world's
corn
and seventy five percent of sunflower
oil
but russia has bombed at least three
civilian ships carrying goods from black
sea ports to the rest of the world
including one chartered by an
agribusiness company
the russian navy is blocking access to
ukraine's ports essentially cutting off
exports of grain
they're reportedly preventing
approximately 94 ships carrying food for
the world market from reaching the
mediterranean
it's no wonder
many shippers are now hesitant to send
vessels into the black sea even to
russian ports given the danger posed by
russian forces russian missiles and
bombs have damaged and destroyed
ukrainian airports rail lines train
stations and highways that are critical
for getting humanitarian aid to those
who need it and for exporting wheat corn
and other commodities
ukrainian foreign mr kaleba has told his
counterparts that russia is actively
targeting grain silos and food storage
facilities
all of these actions by russia are
creating a food crisis in ukraine and
well beyond ukraine's borders
already food prices are skyrocketing and
low and in middle-income countries as
russian choke as russia chokes off
ukrainian exports
across the middle east and africa
already high prices for staple
commodities including wheat have risen
between 20 and 50 percent so far this
year
we are particularly concerned about
countries like lebanon pakistan libya
tunisia yemen and morocco which rely
heavily on ukrainian imports to feed
their
populations the world
as we have heard
was already facing a food security
crisis
well before russia's invasion of ukraine
the covid19 pandemic and the resulting
economic crisis push millions of
families into poverty
countries around the world are grappling
with drought and other disasters made
worse by climate change
as we heard from executive director
beasley the world food program is
already feeding
138 million people in more than 80
countries from ethiopia to afghanistan
south sudan to yemen nigeria to syria
but now
putin's war is driving up the cost of
providing food assistance and the food
and agricultural organization fao
estimates that as many as 13 million
more people worldwide may be pushed into
food insecurity as a result of russia's
invasion of ukraine
many of you have heard the russian
government blame
u.s allied and partner sanctions for
increasing food costs around the world
but the facts the facts colleagues are
clear
sanctions aren't preventing grain from
leaving ukraine's ports
putin's war is
and russia's own food and agricultural
exports are not under sanction by the
u.s
or by our allies and partners
the responsibility for waging war on
ukraine and for the war's effects on
global food security
falls solely
on president putin
the international community must come
together to meet this moment to provide
food water shelter and medicine for the
ukrainian people to support ukraine's
neighbors who have taken in millions of
refugees and to bolster global food
security and protect the world's most
vulnerable from hunger
as a result of putin's war
the united states is committed to doing
our part to ease the human suffering
caused by this war in ukraine and
elsewhere around the world
last week president biden announced that
the united states is prepared to provide
more than one billion dollars in new
humanitarian assistance for the
ukrainian people those fleeing to
neighboring countries and those around
the world feeling the effects of putin's
war including rising food insecurity the
united states has also committed to
provide more than 11 billion dollars
over the next five years to address food
security and nutrition needs around the
world including in countries where food
prices are rising as a result of putin's
invasion of ukraine
but the fact remains
that so long as putin continues his war
so long as russian forces continue to
bombard ukrainian cities and block aid
convoys so long as besieged civilians
are unable to get to safety this
humanitarian crisis will only get worse
in ukraine
for the russian people
and around the world
russia must abide by its obligations
under international humanitarian law on
the protection of civilians including
those who are fleeing conflict and those
who are providing humanitarian
assistance
we hope
we really hope
that president putin will commit
seriously
to the peace talks underway
but we are focused
on what russian forces do
not
what russia says
not
what putin says
and ultimately the only way to end this
humanitarian catastrophe is through
adorable ceasefire and the complete
withdrawal of russian forces from
ukrainian territory
and away from ukraine's borders
that decision
like the decision to begin
this unprovoked
unjustified
war in the first place
lies with one man
and one man only
vladimir putin started this war
he created this global food crisis
and
he is the one who can stop it
thank you madam president
i thank her excellency ms sherman for
her statement i now give the floor to
the permanent representative of kenya
i thank you madam president i thank asg
joyce masuya
and wfp
director david beasley for their
briefings
i also welcome the participation of the
distinguished representative of ukraine
madam president the war in ukraine is a
humanitarian catastrophe
more than 10 million people have fled
their homes
three million have left the country as
refugees
the speed with which the situation has
deteriorated the immense damage to
civilian infrastructure
the shockingly high number of civilian
and military fatalities on both sides
we are reminded of the carnage that we
have only read in the history books and
therefore we fear that it could get far
worse
we offer our heartfelt condolences to
the families who are grieving for their
relatives killed in the violence
we offer condolences as well to the
government of ukraine that must now try
and provide aid
to the people even as it resists a
breaching of its territorial integrity
by the russian federation
we commend ukraine's neighbors for
opening their borders to receive
refugees of multiple nationalities
we urge them to ensure that the
protections sort are offered with no
discrimination on any basis particularly
regarding race or religion
madam president it is not only
ukrainians
who have fled from the bombings
thousands of africans who travel long
distances to seek their education in
ukraine
have also had to flee for their lives
these african students in ukraine and
other parts of the world travel to study
as representatives of their family's
hopes for betterment
thousands made this hopeful journey to
ukraine
now they're fleeing before the tanks and
bomber planes sent into ukraine
they have turned from hopeful students
into fearful refugees
statistics are impersonal
they flattered the human experience
but a humanitarian crisis is human sized
it is a million individual lives
shattered by fear and violence
our delegation spoke to corrine skye
a zimbabwean born student doctor
at nipro medical institute
she had to flee for her safety
joined by her close friends to make a
dangerous 26 hour road trip to live in
western ukraine
it took almost four days to make the
journey and cross the border to safety
at the border she suffered the indignity
and danger of racism
she encountered that racism as she fled
the impersonal brutality of bombs
she then confounded the black women for
black lives
to support thousands of african students
fleeing ukraine
they have raised funds
gotten word out and assisted many who
like them who are fleeing from the
conflict
i urge everyone listening to this
briefing to visit their website as
blackwomenforblacklives.org
for further information about this
heroic effort
today karine is calling for the safety
of civilians
particularly for the african students
trapped in queson
civilians including foreign nationals in
ukraine are not party to the conflict
and must not be made a target
in this regard all actors must
prioritize the protection of civilians
and objects indispensable to their
survival in accordance with
international law and international
humanitarian law
special and urgent attention should be
paid to those trapped in besieged cities
and villages
such as mario paul and kesson
we call for the urgent activation of
safe passages with no restrictions
the response to ukraine's humanitarian
crisis has shown how boldly and
generously the world can react in
solidarity
we commend ocha
the world food programme
and the many other organizations and
individuals who have come to the aid of
the deserving people of ukraine
we urge the european union and its
members
to offer their every support to the
african students who have fled ukraine
it seems eminently doable
that those who have been students
in ukrainian institutions
should receive or can receive offers to
further their education in other
countries as well as the mental health
and material support that they need
we must also not forget our
responsibilities in other humanitarian
crises
very frequently the security council is
briefed on the shortfalls in financing
of humanitarian aid in africa and the
middle east
the situation now is even worse given
the surge in food and energy prices due
to the war in ukraine and its resulting
sanctions
madam president
development is being reversed worldwide
as a result of the war
livelihoods are being destroyed
farmers needing affordable fertilizer
are struggling to cope inflation is
surging upward
the result of these domino-like effects
will be stunted health for millions and
an earlier than normal death for many
others
a few weeks ago we were urging building
back better after covert 19.
now we will need to add the war in
ukraine to that
we urge the secretary general to rally
the united nations the major economies
and international financial institutions
to design instruments that can cushion
the most vulnerable from the effects of
the conflict in ukraine
lacking such action the solidarity
required will eventually suffer
from the rising inequalities and
economic calamities
madam president in the final telling
the most humane action that can be
undertaken is a cessation of hostilities
we call for that association that has
clearly defined contact lines and you
end humanitarian corridors
the cessation of hostilities should set
the foundations for a lasting peace
settlement
that respects the sovereignty
territorial integrity and political
independence of ukraine
it should also lead to the design of a
european security order that offers
lasting security and not a generation of
new wars in europe i thank you
i thank the representative of kenya for
their statement i now give the floor to
the representative of ireland
thank you very much madam president and
i'd like to thank executive director
david bieslyamer abdullah and
assistant secretary general joyce musa
for
updating this council on the
humanitarian catastrophe that is
engulfing the people of ukraine i also
wanted to welcome
our dear colleague from ukraine amongst
us this afternoon
the grim realities that have been shared
with us in the last minutes starkly
demonstrate the human misery caused by
this senseless
and unlawful war
and the roll call of devastation caused
by russia's war goes on
daily we are witnessing the devastating
humanitarian impacts of russia's use of
explosive weapons in populated areas at
least eleven hundred civilian deaths
have now been confirmed by the u n
including over one hundred children
and we all know at this table that the
real figure is likely to be far higher
numbers speak for themselves over 3.9
million refugees have fled for their
lives from russia's invasion
6.5 million people have been displaced
within ukraine's own borders
desperately sheltering from a war with
diminishing resources and little to no
access to basic needs
we are deeply concerned regarding the
increasing vulnerabilities of idps and
refugees as this war continues
reported so-called deportations are
quite frankly abductions
where ukrainian citizens are taken
forcibly across the border and into
russia are simply horrifying
we are also troubled by the activities
of human traffickers to whom this war
offers optimal conditions to prey on
fleeing women and
children i say it again
we condem in the strongest terms acts of
sexual and gender-based violence against
women and violence against children
which have been reported by humanitarian
organizations
this is particularly unconscionable and
frankly ranks amongst the other horrors
being faced by ukrainian citizens
there can be no impunity for those
responsible
we are being warned of an emerging child
protection crisis as the numbers of
unaccompanied and separated children
rises
we have a responsibility to heed those
warnings
we once again call on the russian
federation to uphold their obligations
under international law including
international humanitarian law to allow
full safe and unhindered humanitarian
access for humanitarian personnel in
order for them to reach those in need
the russian federation must also allow
all those seeking to leave ukraine
to do so safely to destinations of their
own choosing
truth is only the russian federation can
prevent
further deterioration of the
humanitarian situation it has caused
president with the world facing a
looming hunger crisis we see now that
the consequences of this senseless war
are being felt far beyond ukraine's
sovereign borders
this unjustified wars already having a
multiplier effect on food and nutrition
and security
compounding other challenges droughts
floods and conflict elsewhere that were
already increasing prices and squeezing
supply chains
the russian federation is one of the
world's biggest grain producers and in
waging an unprovoked war against another
major producer is pushing up the price
of staples
putting even a loaf of bread out of the
reach of those living on the edge of
survival
in addition cruelly ukrainian farmers
are now prevented by war from planting
harvesting and exporting grain
future harvests are therefore already
lost
with longer-term consequences for global
food security
as we've heard
this war has already greatly impacted
the ability of the wfp itself to meet
hunger needs materially and financially
right around the world
president we were warned that 2022 was
set to be a year of catastrophic hunger
now this senseless war has all but
confirmed that ugly catastrophe
as if we needed reminding this war
brings the connection between conflict
and hunger into stark relief
lives are being lost due to the food
insecurity caused by this war
and even if it were to end right now
this afternoon it will still result in
lives lost from hunger into the future
president the war has raged for five
long weeks
five weeks of destruction bombardment
loss of life loss of hope
what is not lost
is our solidarity with the ukrainian
people
that remains steadfast and it remains
resolute
the international community and this
council must not be numbed to the
ongoing tragedy in ukraine
the truth remains as it has for the past
five weeks that this war can end if the
russian federation has the will to end
it
people trapped in need of aid in
besieged cities can be reached
life-saving aid can be delivered through
safe humanitarian access
further flows of desperate vulnerable
refugees can be prevented
countless lives can be saved but only if
the war ends
only if hostilities cease and russia
ends its aggression complies with
obligations under international law
only if the russian federation withdraws
all forces unconditionally from the
entirety of the sovereign territory of
ukraine
we call again on the russian federation
to do the right thing
to end this war
to remember diplomacy to engage in
genuine dialogue in good faith and to
restore peace in ukraine
i continue to believe it's never too
late to do the right thing thank you
president
i thank the representative of ireland
for their statement i give the floor to
the representative of the russian
federation
thank you madam president
today's briefers
today we heard
and you should
likely hear once again
then he calls for a humanitarian truce
providing humanitarian access
humanitarian pauses and humanitarian
corridors
yesterday such initiatives were advanced
by secretary general antonio guterres
colleagues it is hard not to marvel at
your inconsistency just last wednesday
less than a week ago
the majority of you rejected our draft
humanitarian resolution in the council
which would have been binding on all
parties and which contained a specific
list of steps to be undertaken to
unblock the work
of humanitarian agencies
primarily in the east of ukraine
in connection with this today's
statements
particularly those from western
delegations come across as quite
hypocritical
and yet our proposals which were
contained in that draft went much
further than
the list presented by our western
colleagues it also contained demands not
to place
heavy weapons in residential areas not
to use
civilians as a shield
and their adoption by the council could
have saved innumerable lives as the main
threat to
civilians in ukrainian towns and cities
comes from ukrainian
nazis and radicals that are using
civilians as living shields
the internet is full of video evidence
of this from liberated cities or from
those who were able to leave through
humanitarian corridors
even as they were being shelved by
ukrainian armed forces and nationalists
i hope you've seen these images
we're being told that we're allegedly
bombing vessels with grain as well as
grain storage warehouses
the text of the resolution also
contained a demand for
humane and respectful treatment of
prisoners in the context of ukrainian
nazis putting videos on lines which show
them severely mistreating
russian soldiers being held prisoner
and have
russia is strictly complying with its
international obligations and there is
no threat to ukrainians who put down
their arms you can also find evidence of
this in videos on social media
ukrainian nazis do not shy away from the
most sophisticated forms of torture and
reprisals it is enough to mention
the shocking discovery of civilians
tortured to death in nazi uh battalion
torture prisons
with
swastikas branded on their mutilated
bodies
and i have you seen those images
in the context
by ukrainian radicals and special
services of their own citizens we have
serious concerns regarding the measures
being taken by kiev to physically
eliminate undesirable public opinion
leaders
in our letter from march 21st we
officially informed the council
about the abduction by the security
services of ukraine of civil activist
elena
took part in
since then similar reports have been
received regarding vasily volga a
ukrainian opposition politician
a leader of the union of left forces
parties
political sciences dmitry john
opposition political scientist yuri
dudkin
journalist
journalist and publicist dmitry
historian and
public figure
alexander kerrevin
assistant tv host
and editor-in-chief of the odessa
publication timer
yuri
the ukrainian security forces also
carried out a search at the home of
another political science
scientist who's known to the council
mikhail
pogrobinski
we have no information regarding what is
happening to him today and we await fair
assessments
of this kind of witch [ __ ] from our
western colleagues and specialized un
and osc human rights bodies
specific problem the list
of problems
created by kiev keeps growing
added danger in the form of drifting
ukrainian mind has now appeared at ca
bulgaria romania and turkey have already
encountered or will soon encounter this
dangerous problem
in context we would like to emphasize
that the russian armed forces are posing
no threat to
the freedom of civilian navigation
in order to allow foreign vessels to
leave ukrainian ports for open sea we
have
set up a humanitarian corridor which is
80 nautical miles long with a three mile
traffic lane
the corridor is operational daily from 8
a.m to 7 p.m moscow time
this information has been communicated
by us to all interested parties
although our western colleagues did not
support the aforementioned draft
humanitarian resolution in the council
we are one-sidedly implementing all the
humanitarian obligations we have taken
upon ourselves we organize
humanitarian corridors daily
thus today we once again provided 10
routes both towards russia as well as to
the west of ukraine
we're organizing deliveries of essential
goods medicines and food to those in
need
we have already delivered over 6 000
tons of aid to ukraine
and
half a million refugees uh from ukraine
are currently being hosted
communication channels have been
established and are successfully
functioning between the ministry of
defense and mystery foreign affairs of
russia with the leadership of the icrc
and ocha in direct coordination with
icrc we are organizing safe corridors
for the evacuation and for searching and
exchanging prisoners
with the assistance of russian art
forces the
first u.n humanitarian convoy traveled
from full table to sumi
130 tons of humanitarian aid were
delivered
disseminated
wild convoys with tons of food and
essential goods are traveling to ukraine
what's traveling
from the west to ukraine as we all know
is weapons and missiles
today we
heard and will this is again here
a claim about the allegedly imminent
global food crisis
as western delegations presented
it is caused exclusively by russia's
actions in ukraine and putting the
questions this way our western
colleagues are being disingenious
the real reasons
why the global food market is facing
serious turbulence
are by known means in the actions of
russia rather in the unviral sanctions
hysteria that the west has unleashed
against russia
without considering the population of
the so-called global south nor of its
own citizens
attempts to isolate russia economically
financially and logistically from
established years-long channels of
cooperation are
already turning into an economic crisis
of historic proportions
it is clear even to the average observer
that lifting tensions in
logistical and financial relations
ensuring uninterrupted shipments
and stabilizing international
agricultural and food markets
it's possible only by rejecting unlawful
unilateral restrictions
after all the stocks of food produced in
russia haven't decreased
western states themselves who are
capable of preventing hunger and food
shortages no matter how much they may
try to claim the opposite today and
trying to shift the blame to russia
madam president
we also cannot fail to express our
concern over ongoing cases of vehicles
with un insignia being confiscated by
ukraine armed forces it is good that the
secretariat has finally acknowledged
such
offenses uh taking place in kharkiv and
mario
we're awaiting a response to our most
recent inquiry regarding a un vehicle
with diplomatic plates dp210015
which according to witness testimony
took part in combat operations of
ukrainian nationalists
were aware of cases radical using osce
vehicles as well
by the way publications online clearly
show that dhl delivery vehicles have
also fallen to the hands of the
ukrainian army and are being used to
transport weapons we cannot rule out
that the vehicles of these organizations
or vehicles with medical markings are
being used to
transform
the very weapons that the west so
generously promised to kiev from
neighboring states into ukraine and i
hope you understand what reputational
damage such a scenario could deal to all
international entities
concealing
the fact of such vehicles with their
insignia being used for such purposes
in conclusion i would like to respond to
a talking point that has already become
common in the vocabulary of our western
colleagues namely that russia's military
military operation is allegedly an
unprovoked senseless war of choice
this is also a formula that we heard
again today
repeatedly explain what has led to the
current crisis and those who accuse us
of this
are doing that
because
they seek to gloss over their
an anti-russian state for geopolitical
purposes which is uh something that
ukraine has turned into that this has
nothing to do with them
aren't going to talk about wars of
choice then let's recall the us
aggression against yugoslavia iraq libya
afghanistan syria and the vietnam war
all of these states are thousands of
kilometers away from washington and
military warfare they are led to nothing
except hundreds of thousands of ruined
and broken lives leaving behind
completely devastated countries and
condemning millions of people to
destitution and a miserable existence
these were wars of choice because the
united states had a choice
not to start those wars
just as today washington and its allies
has a choice to stop putting out the
fire of the ukrainian crisis with fuel
by supplying the key of regime with
weapons
as well as provoking an international
food crisis and hunger in a number of
states around the world thank you
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for their statement i
now give the floor to the representative
of norway
thank you president
we thank the briefers for their sobering
accounts of the situation on the ground
russia's war against ukraine represents
a blatant violation of national law and
the very principles of the u.n charter
russia's war is causing the largest
humanitarian crisis in europe since
second world war
the damage and destruction to civilian
infrastructure including food system is
devastating
as we had heard so clearly from the
briefers today
the attacks on civilians are simply
unacceptable a quarter of the ukrainian
population has now been displaced
once again we reiterate that
international humanitarian law must be
respected
and the civilian population in ukraine
must be protected
a humanitarian cease-fire in ukraine is
urgently needed and we welcome the
secretary-general's initiative to
request usg griffiths to work directly
with the parties on a possible agreement
we welcome also their renewed dialogue
today between the parties and hope this
will establish the trust needed for an
early agreement on the cessation of
hostilities
president let me highlight just three
areas of concern
first the war is increasing the risk of
sexual and gender-based violence
including sexual violence being used as
a tactic of warfare
this is a great concern
prevention protection and response must
be scaled up
second
immediate action must be taken to shield
children in ukraine from the harms of
conflict
including suffering from a lack of both
urgent and ongoing medical care
many children have fled and are
unaccompanied accompanied they are
extremely vulnerable and must be
protected
and third the massive displacement and
refugee flows have led to reports of
significant increase in human
trafficking
this needs to be urgently addressed by
all including the un and receiving
states
president ukrainians are responding with
great courage and commitment and we
recognize the leading role women are
playing in the response
the work undertaken by international
humanitarian organizations and their
local partners and responders
is crucial
systematic engagement between them
together with affected people needs to
be strengthened
as the needs grow their efforts and
ability to stay and deliver must be
accelerated humanitarian organization
must be allowed safe rapid and unimpeded
humanitarian access to people in need
we commend also the hospitality and
solidarity extended by ukraine's
neighbors and we encourage countries to
keep their borders open to all those
seeking protection without
discrimination
president the secretary-general undp and
other development organizations are
sounding the alarm about regional and
even global consequences of the war
this is both a humanitarian and
development crisis
it is both a ukrainian and a global
crisis
ukraine itself has been set back decades
in its economic development more than 60
percent of its citizen could fall below
the poverty line within the next 12
months
the conflict will have a serious
negative effect on the agricultural
sector
likely leading to a global rise in food
insecurity and increased prices of fuel
and fertilizer all contributing to
social unrest and instability across the
world
the ripple effects of the russian
aggression will be particularly felt by
those living in conflict and crisis
affected countries like syria yemen
afghanistan ethiopia and south sudan we
therefore welcome the secretary
general's initiative to establish a
global crisis response group on food
energy and finance
president
russia's aggression has long-term
consequences for ukraine it exacerbates
other humanitarian crises and it
undermines global economic development
peace and security
russia must stop this unjust war
this is the only way to end the
humanitarian catastrophe in ukraine and
beyond thank you
i thank the representative of norway for
their statement i now give the floor to
the representative of india
thank you madam president
let me begin by thanking assistant
secretary general joyce mizuya and the
world food program executive director
david beasley for their briefings on the
humanitarian situation in ukraine
india remains deeply concerned at the
ongoing situation which continues to
deteriorate since the beginning of the
hostilities
we reiterate our call for unimpeded
humanitarian access to areas of armed
conflict in ukraine
there is an urgent need to address the
humanitarian needs of the affected
population
in this regard the initiatives of the un
and its agencies like ocha and wfp have
reinforced ongoing efforts
we also note the decision by the eu
countries who have agreed to a permit
free transit of humanitarian carriers to
ukraine we hope the international
community will continue to respond
positively to the humanitarian needs of
the people of ukraine including through
extending generous support to the
secretary general's flash appeal and the
regional refugee response plan on
ukraine
keeping in view that dire humanitarian
situation unfolding in ukraine india has
already sent over 90 tons of
humanitarian supplies to ukraine and its
neighbors
these supplies have included medicines
and other essential relief material for
refugees
we are providing more humanitarian
assistance in the coming days especially
through supply of essential medicines
allow me to underscore that it is
important that humanitarian action is
always guided by the principles of
humanitarian assistance which is
humanity neutrality impartiality and
independence embedded as they are at the
heart of human guiding principles of
humanitarian assistance
these measures should not be politicized
the conflict is already having an impact
on the global economy especially on many
developing countries including through
disruption of supply chains its adverse
impact on energy and commodity prices is
evident
we reiterate our call for immediate
secession of hostilities across ukraine
our prime minister on several occasions
has reiterated this and emphasized that
there is no other option but the path of
dialogue and diplomacy
we continue to emphasize that the global
order is anchored in international law
the u.n charter and respect for the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
states
we call for purposeful engagement by
both sides in the ongoing talks
we hope that an understanding could be
reached soon
it is clearly in our collective interest
to find a solution that can provide for
immediate de-escalation of tensions amid
aimed at securing long-term peace and
stability in the region and beyond i
thank you
i thank the representative of india for
their statement i now give the floor to
the representative of ghana
thank you madam president
i'd like to begin by thanking the
assistant secretary general for
humanitarian affairs and deputy
emergency relief coordinator joyce mucia
and the executive director of the world
food programme david brisley for their
briefings i also welcome the
participation in this meeting of the
representative of ukraine
madam president almost a week after the
general assembly voted in a landmark
resolution with an
equivocal call for the immediacization
of hostilities and the return to the
path of dialogue and diplomacy the signs
on the ground are yet to reflect the
sentiments of the international
community for an early improvement in
the humanitarian situation in ukraine
the call for an unconditional and
immediate ceasefire and for the
withdrawal of all the invading troops
from the internationally recognized
borders of ukraine are critical to save
lives and prevent further devastation to
the ukrainian people
it remains fundamental to addressing the
western humanitarian conditions
ghana remains deeply concerned about the
continuing military bombardment of
cities and civilian populated areas of
ukraine and is disheartened by the
trauma that the situation has caused
especially to the aged women and
children we note with regret the loss of
lives the displacement of people and
overall suffering of the ukrainian
people from this needless war
never has it been necessary done now for
the parties to the conflict to urgently
commit to a humanitarian pause to enable
the evacuation and safe passage of
civilians and facilitate the delivery of
food
medicine and other essential services to
those in critical need who have been
caught up in cities under siege
we also deplore the attacks on medical
facilities and call for the protection
of humanitarian workers and medical
personnel we urge the parties to comply
with their commitments under
international law an international
humanitarian law in particular the
provisions of the for geneva convention
of 1949
relative to the protection of civilian
persons in the time of war
ghana also encourages neighboring
countries of ukraine to facilitate the
free passage of persons fleeing the war
without discrimination and provide them
with humanitarian assistance including
medical care in line with the principles
of humanity neutrality and impartiality
madam president we continue to remain
concerned by the transmission of the
shocks of the war in ukraine within the
global economy and the disproportionate
impacts that developing countries and
small economies are having to bear on
account of this war many of whom are
already caught in the throes of the
covet 19 pandemic
we reiterate our call for urgent
international solidarity on the issues
of sovereign release of sx food stocks
calibrated intervention in the oil
market and new debt initiatives and
financial asset mechanisms to help
maintain global cohesion and stability
at this precarious time
we note the reported intention of the
russian federation to redeploy it forces
from certain parts of ukraine and
airchair to follow through in the
ongoing dialogue in turkey aimed at a
pathway to resolving the crisis i thank
you
i thank the representative of ghana for
their statement i give the floor to the
representative of the united kingdom
thank you madam president and i join
others in thanking asg masuya and
executive director david beasley for
their briefings
so we've heard once again today
the appalling impact on the ukrainian
people
of president putin's senseless war of
choice
10.3 million people are displaced
73 confirmed attacks on hospitals and
medical centers
659 schools and kindergartens damaged
the devastation in mariupol is almost
beyond description
civilians remain
without food
water
electricity
people are reportedly resorting to
drinking
not just snow but sewage water to
survive
there are credible reports of mass
graves
forced deportations of residents to the
russian federation
as well as incidents of sexual violence
and use of landmines
there will be accountability for these
crimes
so there is an urgent need to alleviate
humanitarian suffering in ukraine
we note the secretary general's
announcement yesterday
about martin griffith's role in pursuing
a humanitarian
and we're grateful for the latest data
from archer the world food programme and
in the secretary general's statement
yesterday
about those they've been able to reach
we encourage all efforts
to help the people of ukraine
in agreement with the ukrainian
government
the uk will continue to play its part
we have provided 400 million pounds to
support ukraine
including
220 million pounds in humanitarian aid
and we call for close cooperation
between the un agencies and other donors
to ensure this assistant reaches and
protects the most vulnerable
but let us be without a shred of doubt
as the secretary general set out
yesterday
the only way to end the suffering
is for russia to end the war
global commodity prices were already on
the rise before the invasion
as economies recovered from the covet
pandemic
we now see
spiraling energy prices and global food
insecurity
hitting the most vulnerable
the hardest
almost every u n member state
is now suffering
because of russia's war
as david beasley said
we now risk
famine destabilization
and we risk
having to take food
from hungry children
for starving children
russia's appetite for war
is taking food
off the world's table
madam president
the uk welcomes the general assembly
resolution adopted last week
un member states sent an overwhelming
message
that russia alone
is to blame for the humanitarian crisis
in ukraine
and for the shocks being felt globally
for the suffering to end
russian bullets and bombs must stop
and russian tanks and troops must go
home
i thank you madam president
i thank the representative of the united
kingdom for their statement i now give
the floor to the representative of
albania
thank you madam president
whoever seeks the truth about ukraine
today comes to the same conclusion
russian aggression has caused a
catastrophic humanitarian situation in
ukraine
it must end and give negotiations not
just a chance but the real place
with an immediate national nationwide
ceasefire as 140 u.n member states asked
for just last week
unfortunately as we speak people are
still being killed
dear colleagues
at the end of world war ii some 40
million people had been displaced from
their homes
in ukraine only after five weeks a
quarter of the country's population of
44 million have been displaced by the
russian aggression
we were told repeatedly that this war
does not concern civilians
but actually it has become mainly a war
between the russian army and ukrainian
civilians civilian people including
women and children
mario paul
savagely battered into rubble and
reduced to ashes symbolizes the extreme
brutality of the russian
invasion
in the words of the mayor of the city
russian aim is to wipe the city off the
face of the earth along with its
inhabitants
there is a legal definition for this
despicable practice
we know it by history records
cruelty inflicts untold damage and pain
but it never prevails
it did not during world war ii
it did not during the three long years
of siege of sarajevo and during the
genocide in srebrenica
it did not during the horrible massacres
and massive ethnic cleansing in kosovo
and we know all that all those who tried
those who suffer from the strong man's
syndrome how they end it
at best behind bars
bombing schools hospitals commercial
centers theaters and cinemas with modern
weapons has killed many and terrified
many more
but it has not demoralized nor broken
ukrainians
instead it has marked the russian
failure it and it has sealed its
humiliation
ukrainians men and women are not
fighting fighting to survive but to win
as they and they will
dear colleagues
no propaganda can beat facts
half of the entire children of the
country of 44 million are displaced
nearly 4 500 residential buildings over
nine factories and enterprises more than
650 educational establishments 74
healthcare institutions have been
damaged or destroyed in ukraine
in kharkiv alone more than a thousand
houses have been destroyed by russia
this extensive damage is not only the
consequence
it is in fact the real aim of the
aggressor
unable to occupy the country
it is simply destroying it
dear colleagues
the russian invasion of ukraine has
caused major implications for food
security across the world
as u.n reports confirm it
it is inflicting severe challenges to
developing countries
this comes when 2022 is believed to
become a year of catastrophic hunger
with more than 44 million people in 38
countries on the edge of famine
and overall global needs for
humanitarian assistance are higher than
ever
people in conflict areas fear dying of
war
now they fear dying of hunger as well
this is another consequence of russia's
war
dear colleagues troubling facts confirm
that russia has replaced the right of
information with the freedom of
disinformation
novae gazetta one of the largest
independent investigative newspapers in
russia led by nobel prize winner dimitri
muratov
announced that it was forced to hold
publication after being issued a warning
from the government
you cannot tell the truth they were told
you cannot speak of war
how many times have we heard
in the most ridiculed posture that
ukrainians are inflicting all this to
themselves
this is what russians are told
relentlessly now in an almost closed
circuit information system
how masochist would they be those
ukrainians if it weren't for a simple
fact they have been aggressed in their
home and they are fighting to defend it
total information blackout will keep
russians into darkness
burning them into a parallel and
distorted reality through propaganda
until mothers start looking for their
missing boys
dear colleagues
human human human rights team in ukraine
have received information about mass
graves in the besieged city of maripour
other horrors will soon be unearthed
everything must be done to ensure
accountability of every war crime
committed in ukraine
the group of friends on accountability
following the aggression in ukraine
recently established will support all
efforts to gather evidence and document
the atrocities of the war
madam president let me end with the
reality check
now we know
russia wanted all ukraine
it learned the hard way it cannot and
will not get it
now it wants to divide it and grab a
part
this must not be tolerated it must be
condemned and held accountable and i
thank you
i thank the representative of albania
for their statement i give the floor to
the representative of gabon
thank you
i would like to thank the assistant
secretary general
joyce masuya and
and on the ground hostility is
continuing
against civilian infrastructure as well
as those attacks that directly impact
the supply of
vitals
red cross data
today
indicates some 18 million people who
need urgent humanitarian assistance in
ukraine
of which nine hundred thousand
could be rescued and welcomed by the u.s
specialized
living conditions which goes hand in
hand with an increase
urgently to thousands of people
both
who stayed in their country as well as
those who decided to flee the zones of
combat in order to
know
that many of those fleeing are majority
women and children
indicating that there's a risk of
disease stemming from the fact that it's
difficult to have access to
drinking water
and clean infrastructure with the
corollary of hygiene problems
are also a source of concern
food shortages in the three months to
come with some forty percent of
absurd zones impacted
in those
who are facing distress due to this
beyond the momentum of international
solidarity which has not wavered since
the 24th
and which translated in particular
larger mobilization
and all of those suffering at their side
due to
the acts which are in proportion to
mistakes
my country is of the view that the
humanitarian issue is in ukraine
needs to be grappled with in an isolated
conditions of respect for the protection
of civilians
war zones
providing access to humanitarian rights
this is the vocation of humanitarian law
and no doubt
it's also important for other issues
which are on the council's agenda
madam president i'd like to reiterate
my country's appreciation
for the neighboring countries of ukraine
that continue to mobilize to urgently
welcome the refugees
and we would call for an equitable
treatment of all persons suffering from
distress
we once again call on the warring
parties to respect the provisions of
international law
and humanitarian law specifically
the geneva convention of 1949.99 and
it's additional protocols and guaranteed
respect and protection of medical staff
and humanitarian workers
we call on the parties to commit
to opening humanitarian corridors that
are secure and we call for immediate
cessation hostilities dear colleagues
the fight should not stop due to a lack
of fighters as the french writer
they would say the fight should stop
because we mobilized to find an
agreement
which is in keeping with what is at
stake in the political humanitarian
security arenas for all of the
protagonists
my country is very attentive to the
negotiations which are taking place
currently between the parties in
istanbul and hope
parties
in their quest for a political solution
to the crisis and a way out of the war
thank you i thank the representative of
gabon for their statement i now give the
floor to the representative of brazil
thank you very much madam president
uh let me start by thanking the briefers
as jim suyer and executive director
beasley for their presentations
and most of all for the tireless efforts
of both orchard and the wfp
in helping to alleviate the humanitarian
situation in ukraine
let me also welcome the permanent
representative of ukraine to this
meeting
as we enter into another week of
hostilities we continue to witness the
intense human suffering it is causing
the briefings today highlight yet
another grave dimension of the war
one that affects all countries
particularly developing states
food insecurity
brazil is concerned
with the worsening of the global food
crisis
the ongoing conflict is already causing
a decline in food supplies and a surge
in food prices
according to fao
around 50 countries depend on imports of
wheat from russia and ukraine
not count other food products and
services
och's global humanitarian overview for
2022 has already alerted that food
insecurity is at unprecedented levels
i would like to recall one sentence from
the overview and i quote
without sustained and immediate action
2022 could be catastrophic
end quote
now
the most worrying part is that this
assessment came before the conflict in
ukraine erupted
now
the prospects are even worse
while the humanitarian needs are higher
the resources are still scarce
which is only aggravated by rising food
prices
it is deeply worrying to know that wfp
has already had to reduce assistance for
refugees and other vulnerable
populations
across east africa and the middle east
adding to the direct consequences of the
conflict in ukraine
the indiscriminate imposition of broad
economic
sanctions may further affect food
insecurity
unilateral sanctions are not only
illegal under national law international
law
as currently applied they jeopardize
access to products
that are essential to the survival of a
large portion of the world's population
in the end
they tend to be heavily detrimental to
developing countries
while some developed countries can
protect
their interests and guarantee the
well-being of their own population
through sustained funds during the next
years
madam president
the general assembly has recently
adopted a resolution about the
humanitarian situation in ukraine
with the support of brazil
in our explanation of vote
we highlighted that the general assembly
could not become a bystander of the
shocking images from the conflict and
the desperation of civilians trapped in
the battlefield
neither can the security council
as the main u.n organ with primary
responsibility for the maintenance of
international peace and security
the security council has the mandate
and the responsibility
to address the situation in an effective
manner
we should strive to create the
conditions for increased dialogue on
practical measures to minimize human
suffering in ukraine
civilians wishing to flee the
hostilities must be able to do so in
safety
and those who decide to stay
cannot become targets of attacks
in the same vein parties must grant safe
passage to relief consignments to those
in need
excuse me
the situation in mario paul is
particularly concerning
we call on all parties to work towards
concrete agreements to allow civilians
to leave the city if they so wish
parties should spare no efforts to
prevent people
from going missing and to share
information on the status of protected
persons under their control
once again
brazil reiterates the call for all
parties to fully respect and ensure
respect for international humanitarian
law
no matter the causes of a conflict
once it erupts
civilians must be safe
the wounded must receive medical care
humanitarian assistance
assistance must reach those in need
and detainees must be treated humanely
in all circumstances
there must be no politicization of
humanitarian messages nor selective
applications of international
humanitarian law
also
geopolitical objectives must not
supersede the endeavor for peace
nor prolong the human suffering caused
by war
madam president
the forecasts of most humanitarian
organizations were already catastrophic
for 2022.
this conflict apart from the enormous
human suffering and devastation caused
in ukraine
will have spillover effects on the
entire world
making it
making it even more difficult to
alleviate the dire situation of
civilians in conflict toward countries
the longer the conflict drags on
the higher the risk of further
instability hunger and devastation in
ukraine and elsewhere
it is high time to return to the path of
dialogue and diplomacy for a peaceful
settlement of the conflict
we urgently need the cessation of
hostilities
de-escalation of tensions and
negotiations are the only way out of
this conflict
not only for the countries directly
involved
but also for the whole world
i thank you
i thank the representative of brazil for
their statement i give the floor to the
representative of china
us
the situation on the ground the conflict
situation in ukraine is persistent
effectively protecting civilian lives
and meeting their humanitarian needs is
a must
china calls for respect for
international humanitarian law
to avoid civilian casualties to the
maximum extent protect civilian
securities provide safe passage for
evacuation and humanitarian access
and ensure
a continuous supply of basic necessities
agencies
and coordinate international support to
provide emergency humanitarian relief to
conflict with affected populations
and to help ukraine and its neighboring
countries meet with the enormous
humanitarian needs
madam president
we must also
and will continue to do so affecting the
life and livelihoods of the general
public and giving rise to new criminal
problems
developing countries which make up the
majority of them
are not parties
and should not be drawn into team
confrontation and forced to suffer about
consequences of geopolitical clashes
inspiring among major councils
global food security is being seriously
challenged which was
further disrupt food production and food
supply chain across the world push up
food prices and put such burdens on
developing countries as they do
we call for enhanced international
coordination to stabilize funds from
food prices refrain from
and other agencies
should actively contribute
to coordinating
food production
among countries and helping developing
countries
if
negotiation the international community
should encourage and support continued
direct negotiations between russia and
ukraine until a positive outcome is
achieved and peace is understandable
security hitting one block against
another is precisely the most assured
way to achieve insecurity the united
nations
nato and the eu should also engage in
dialogue with when she accommodate the
legitimate security concerns of all
parties and build a balanced effective
and sustainable regional security
architecture through dialogue
china will continue to work towards and
play a constructive role in easing
i thank the representative of china for
their statement i shall now make a
statement in my capacity as the
representative of the united arab
emirates
i thank both the assistant secretary
general for humanitarian affairs ms
joyce mitsuya and the executive director
of the world food programme mr david
beasley for their valuable briefings
each meeting and briefing that we hold
on the deteriorating humanitarian
situation in ukraine underscores the
war's devastating impact on the lives of
civilians and the failure of the
international community to alleviate
their suffering
we are deeply concerned by the
increasing casualties destruction and
damage to civilian infrastructure
in particular we deplore the rate of
displacement which has seen nearly a
quarter of ukraine's population more
than 10 million idps and refugees most
of whom are women and children flee
their homes in just one month of
fighting
we reiterate the importance of an
immediate cessation of all hostilities
throughout ukraine we also welcome
yesterday's request from the u.n
secretary general that martin griffiths
work with the parties involved to
explore the possibility of humanitarian
ceasefire in ukraine and we were pleased
to hear today from ocha that there was a
positive response on both sides
we strongly support aid agencies as they
uphold the principles of humanity
neutrality impartiality and independence
and as they coordinate with all parties
to ensure safe and unhindered access for
humanitarian workers
in light of the dire situation the uae
believes that it is important to focus
on the following key points in order to
help those in need most effectively
first we commend the role of
humanitarian organizations and ocher in
rapidly responding under extreme
pressure to the needs of civilians their
efforts during the conflict have made it
possible to provide aid to nearly one
million people we also commend the push
to develop an integrated system of aid
operations throughout the country
we support och's efforts to create a
humanitarian notification mechanism for
the safe delivery of aid we would also
like to see work done building on the
un's coordination with ukraine and the
russian federation which led to
humanitarian convoys delivering aid to
sumi and most recently harkief
second the uae reiterates the importance
of all parties complying with
international humanitarian law
especially to protect civilians limit
military operations to exclusively
military objectives and take all
precautionary measures
we stress the need for keeping lines of
communication open between all parties
to coordinate the safe delivery of aid
in a practical and effective manner as
well as following through on proposals
for the dignified treatment of the dead
so they can be identified have their
families informed and their bodies
returned on all sides
we further emphasize the importance of
securing temporary ceasefire agreements
in specific areas to allow civilians to
evacuate to safety to securely deliver
aid to civilians in need and to ensure
the protection of humanitarian workers
third we call for intensifying
diplomatic contacts between the two
parties to find a peaceful solution and
we fully support all media mediation
efforts in this regard we took note of
the positive reports from the talks
conducted in istanbul today as well as
other ongoing mediation efforts
it is our sincere hope that they will
lead to a diplomatic solution
in this context we also stress the
important role of women in conflict
resolution and peace negotiations
including here to ensure their
sustainability and durability
we should all be alarmed by the wfp's
briefing today as they note ukraine and
russia together are a critical
breadbasket for the world
the rising food insecurity is wreaking
havoc on pandemic recovery particularly
for developing least developed and small
island developing states in the middle
east and africa the conflict jeopardizes
significant sources of wheat including
from many countries on this council's
agenda
this could lead to further unrest and
instability around the world
in conclusion the uae reaffirms its
commitments to the humanitarian response
which we have contributed to both
bilaterally and through the un's flash
humanitarian appeal
we also reiterate the importance of
constructive security council engagement
towards alleviating the humanitarian
crisis in ukraine and more broadly to
help encourage the urgent diplomatic
resolution of this conflict
i now resume my function as president of
this council
and her excellency ms wendy sherman
deputy secretary of state of the united
states of america has asked for the
floor to make a further statement i give
her the floor
thank you very much and thank you for
giving me this opportunity today i much
appreciate it madam president
um i feel that i must make uh four
critical points
first i want to be clear that the
conflict that
is being suffered by the ukrainian
people
is not about the russian federation
versus the west
140 countries just last week
spoke in support of ending this conflict
and the need to end this humanitarian
crisis
141 countries supported the initial
resolution
in the un general assembly
to say that this invasion by russia
should stop
so with all due respect
mr ambassador this is not about russia
versus the west this is about the
support of the u.n charter and the
principles of sovereignty territorial
integrity and the right of all countries
all countries
to choose their political orientation
and their foreign policy
second
i myself was engaged directly
with russian counterparts
to find a peaceful way forward
to meet the concerns of the russian
federation
i sat opposite
russian counterparts
and put on the table
many options to address the concerns we
provided as does nato
a paper
of very specific ways
in which we could address reciprocally
and mutually security concerns president
putin
chose an invasion
not diplomacy
third
with all due respect mr ambassador
as a jewish american i cannot help
but say this is not
about nazis in ukraine
last week
former u.s secretary of state
and former permanent representative to
this council
and one of my most cherished personal
friends
madeleine albright died
she loved representing the united states
here
she would have been outraged
by the words of the russian federation
today
later in her life she learned
that her parents raised her as catholic
to protect her
from the nazis because
her family was jewish
she learned that three of her
grandparents
died
at the hands of the nazis
while in concentration camps
she knew that the jewish president
of ukraine
was certainly not a nazi
and that the citizens of ukraine
being slaughtered
and starving
and without food and medicine and the
subject of this humanitarian
dialogue today
are not
and never were
nazis
and finally
dialogue today
is about the humanitarian needs
of ukrainian civilians
and the humanitarian needs of people
around the world
who as david beasley said so eloquently
are going
from
feeding starving children
feeding hungry children
to
feeding starving children
it's about as he said
going from a bread basket to a bread
line
we must all do whatever we can of course
to stop war
but there is an easy choice here
and it is a choice that can be made
today
in istanbul
by president putin
and that is to stop the war
so let us all
over 140 countries around the world
continue to stand with ukraine
thank you
i thank her excellent zima sherman for
her statement
and i'd like to give the floor to the
representative of the russian federation
who has asked to make a further
statement i give them the floor
[Music]
your participation in the negotiations
of course you're very well informed
about this much better so than i or my
colleagues are but
because the negotiations did not succeed
then perhaps you fell short in some way
in this area and perhaps
you should have worked better and uh
should have proposed more made more
serious proposals but now we are where
we are
and i'd like to comment on your words
regarding nazism in ukraine
it has already
become a common excuse
[Music]
you know
how many things these people did that
were harmful that were bad for humanity
these were people who collaborated with
nazis who
took part in the killings of polls of
jews of russians of ukrainians
if you have any doubts
the polish people about this not polish
politicians but the ordinary people i've
worked in poland for three years and i'm
very well aware of how they view bandara
bandera and trevig are national heroes
of ukraine
the national battalions
in their insignia have nazi symbols
a portrait of a ukrainian woman
from its official page because there was
a nazi symbol
on her
military tortures people and brands
military
nazi symbols on their bodies you don't
consider that to be nazism and if the
president of a country
considers the national hero of a country
to be someone who fought alongside
hitler
killing jews polls russians and
ukrainians well apparently from your
point of view this doesn't mean anything
as well but we
see things otherwise and so do the
majority of the people in russia and
ukraine thank you
i thank the representative of the
russian federation for their statement
i now give the floor to the
representative of ukraine
madam president
distinguished members of the security
council assistant secretary
general
executive director beasley
i also recognize the representative of
the aggressive state present here
in the permanent seat of the soviet
union
who is in fact is not authorized to
speak on behalf of the ukrainian people
as he just
at did outset i would like to inform you
that the demilitarization of russia
conducted by the ukrainian army
and supported by the entire ukrainian
people is well on the way
since the beginning of the invasion
the russian occupiers have lost more
than
17 000 military personnel
more than 1700 armored vehicles
almost 600 tanks
over 300 artillery systems
127 planes
and 129 helicopters
almost 100 rocket launchers systems
54 air defense systems and seven ships
that is under that is an unprecedented
blow to moscow
where the numbers of soviet losses in
afghanistan pale in comparison
however after listening to russia's
ambassador
i regret to say
that the process of deputization is
lagging behind so far
today's negotiations in istanbul have
demonstrated that russia may be ready to
make steps forward
although
it is still a long way
to a sustainable ceasefire
and comprehensive de-escalation
the parties will continue consultations
to prepare and agree on provisions of a
treaty on the security guarantees for
ukraine
a mechanism of implementation of the
ceasefire withdrawal of forces
and other armed formations opening and
safe functioning of humanitarian
corridors on a permanent basis
as well as on the exchange of fallen
soldiers
and the release of prisoners of war and
civilians
signing of the treaty on the security
guarantees for ukraine will only be
possible after withdrawal of all russian
armed units two locations as on 23rd
february 2022
the negotiation process which is
underway by no means removes the need to
provide to ukraine additional assistance
with weapons and to implement new
sanctions imposed on the russian
federation for the act of aggression
committed
dear colleagues last week
the overwhelming majority of the un
membership expressed once again
its resolute stance towards russia's
unprovoked and unjustified invasion of
in ukraine
strong humanitarian messages addressed
to russia left no room for
misinterpretation and neither did
attempts by the aggressor to shift
responsibility on the victim
we demand that russia immediately and
unconditionally implement all provisions
of the un general assembly resolution
es11 ii humanitarian consequences of the
aggression against ukraine
to elevate humanitarian suffering on the
ground
i regret to say that as of now russia
demonstrates no willingness to give up
his strategy of deliberate aggravation
of the humanitarian situation on the
ground
there is a clear nexus between the hard
security the humanitarian situation and
food security with regard to the russian
war against ukraine
after the failure of its initial plan
for blitzkrieg
russian troops have proceeded to plan b
this plan envisages provoking
humanitarian disaster throughout ukraine
and destroying the agricultural
potential of my country to intimidate
the ukrainian political leadership and
people and to incline them to surrender
the toolbox is broad and extremely cruel
it includes deliberate destruction of
residential areas and critical
infrastructure
missile shelling throughout the country
the besiege of cities
violation of arrangements on
humanitarian corridors
terror against civilians in the occupied
areas including abductions and killings
as of now the invaders abducted about 30
local leaders
activists and journalists
it is hard to imagine that russia
fired
467 missiles at residential areas only
with the overall number being 100 1200
this includes ballistic missiles cruise
missiles
and supersonic missiles
this number has already made the russian
actions the heaviest missile shelling
ever in such a short period of
time mario paul remains a bleeding wound
in the heart of europe
according to the local authorities at
least 5 000 people were killed
almost 150 000 residents remain under
siege deprived of any basic conditions
to leave
they need to be evacuated but not to the
territory of the of the aggressor
russian attempts to do so are not only
cynical
hypocrisy but a gross violation of the
laws and customs of all
the norms of international humanitarian
law in particular the geneva convention
of 1949 an additional protocol
one to the geneva conventions
as now
about 40 000 ukrainians were forcibly
deported to russia and belarus
at the same time the russian armed
forces resort to firing at evacuation
convoys trying to leave mariupol for
known for the non-occupied territory of
ukraine
according to you to unicef one month of
war in ukraine has led to the
displacement of 4.3 million children
more than half of the country's
estimated 7.5 million child population
including more than 1.8 million children
who left the country as refugees
at least 143 children were killed by
russian invaders and 216 injured
humanitarian action is urgently needed
at the same time we should bear in mind
that the humanitarian disaster in
ukraine is an element of the russian war
strategy
to be efficient any initiative should be
focused on changing the overall russian
approach towards ukraine instead of idle
attempts to engage the aggressor as a
partner on the humanitarian track
i also reiterate my call to join the
group of friends of accountability
following the aggression against ukraine
which was launched last friday and
already includes almost 50 member states
distinguished colleagues
the third element of the nexus food
security is also under threat
on the global
level we are aware that the entire world
is deeply concerned over the
disruption of food supplies from ukraine
as one of the major food exporters
before the war more than 55 percent of
all sunflower oil in the world was
exported from ukraine
more than 55 percent of ukrainian wheat
was exported to asia
and 40 percent of ukrainian wheat was
exported to african states
about 400 million people throughout the
world mostly in the middle east north
africa and asia
depend on grain supplies from ukraine
what we in ukraine are also alarmed
about is that 40 million ukrainians may
face food shortages already this year
this prompts the government of ukraine
to work intensively on both tracks
to secure the country's expert potential
to the largest extent possible and to
ensure that ukrainians who bear the
primary burden of russia's aggression
will not suffer from hunger
international solidarity with ukraine
and understanding that the only root
cause of the current food crisis is
russia's war against ukraine will be
crucial to succeed in averting the worst
case scenario
on the global level
it is extremely important therefore not
to spam our discussion with references
to those issues that are not the root
causes but rather implications of
russia's ongoing violations
it must be clear that vulnerable
countries will remain at risk as long as
russia continues its war in ukraine
which includes shelling the agricultural
infrastructure
contaminating the ukrainian soil
deliberately targeting fuel storages and
thus disrupting the sowing and
harvesting campaign
for instance this weekend alone
russian missiles hit fuel storages in
live dubno
luzk and rimney
all in the west of the country far away
from the front line
just today the russian troops shelled
with missiles a farm enterprise in in
dimpro
also far away from the combat area
destroying vehicles and equipment
perhaps the representative of the
aggressive state could explain
what the reason was for this attack
demilitarization
or densification
all ukrainian seaports remain blocked by
russia
thus further aggravating the situation
with supply shortages
some of them have been occupied
the occupation and lifting the blockade
could quickly improve the situation as
60 percent of agricultural products were
exported by ukraine through its seaports
under these extraordinary circumstances
the government of ukraine
takes comprehensive measures to respond
to food security challenges
the sowing campaign is due to start on
70
of agricultural lands
the government has also launched an
interest-free loan program for farmers
to strengthen their capabilities against
the block drop
sorry against the backdrop of the wall
steps to reorient the supply chains by
switching to safe routes are being taken
as well
we are ready to discuss the food
security issues in detail
with all interested actors
at the same time however we are not able
to proceed to details in the presence of
the representative of russia
as food security or other food
insecurity has been and remains one of
the main elements of russia's military
planning and it is actions on the ground
the russian occupants act under the
motor
the worse it is the better
and it is highly likely that as soon as
moscow receives the report of the
russian ambassador the list of russian
targets will be amended with new items
we do not want all ukrainian black soils
to be sown with mines and all
agricultural infrastructure destroyed
in fact putin is not the first dictator
to weaponize food against the ukrainian
nation
moscow's ideological apostle stalin
killed millions of ukrainians 90 years
ago
in the artificially organized great
famine
it is not surprising therefore that
putin who venerates stalin as his
forefather resorts to the same practice
madam president
let me quote
a written message recently conveyed from
besieged mariupol
by one of its residents
to his relative
i quote
dima
mommy was killed on the 9th of march
2022
she died very quickly
then the house was burned down
dima forgive me that i did not protect
her
i buried her
near the kindergarten
end of quote
this written message with a makeshift
map
is a sign of several lives ruined by
russia
several out of thousands in the in the
one city of mariupol alone
millions throughout ukraine
this is the price
for the war the world failed to prevent
this is the price for the sick mind of
the russian dictator
and most of his people
civilized nations tolerated it for so
long in a naive hope
that the kremlin could stop at lust
in the meantime russian society
continues to remain in denial
however
as it happened after the defeat of
nazism
when its supporters were taken to the
size of holocaust
to break their denial
and to open their eyes wide
the time will come
when the supporters of putinism
will be taken to ukrainian cities and
villages
burned to the ground
to the mass graves of thousands of
ukrainians
killed by the russian invaders
i will conclude
with quoting
from today's video address of my
president
i start the quote the signals we hear
from the negotiations
can be called
positive
but these signals do not drown out
the ruptures of russian shells
ukrainians have already learned during
these 34 days of invasion
and over the past eight years of the war
indones
that only a concrete result can be
trusted
end of quote
and the lies poured out on us here like
slope
by putin's representative
is a vivid confirmation
of this
i thank you
i thank the representative of ukraine
for their statement there are no more
names inscribed on the list of speakers
the meeting is adjourned
this is
[Music]
um